- [Narrator] Here's how you
make a Cozy Cone Motel inspired
bacon mac and cheese cone at home.
Start by rolling card
stock into a cone shape
and covering in aluminum foil,
and coat with a non-stick cooking spray.
Next, roll a package of pizza
dough into a large rectangle
and cut into one-inch strips.
Starting at the point of the cone,
wrap the strips around.
Coat with egg wash
and bake in a 425-degree
oven for 12 to 15 minutes.
Next, the mac and cheese.
Start by cooking a pound of pasta
according to the directions,
then cook your bacon and allow it to cool.
Now onto the cheese sauce.
Start by melting a 1/4 cup of butter
in a saucepan over medium heat
and then add a 1/4 cup of flour
and cook until golden and smooth.
Then add two cups of milk
and whisk until smooth
and let the mixture
thicken over medium heat.
Add 1/2 cup of cream
cheese, allowing to melt.
Then eight ounces of
shredded cheddar cheese
and salt and pepper to taste.
Stir until smooth.
Add in your cooked noodles
and mix to combine.
Fill your cones with the mac and cheese,
top with the bacon,
and enjoy.
Let's make some iconic Disney snacks.
Here are my top five Disney recipes
you need to make at home.
The Cheeseburger Pods from Pandora
are always one of my favorites,
and if you want a good
hack for this recipe,
you always can use flaky biscuits
from a tube for the buns.
The Totchos from Woody's Lunchbox
are always a fan favorite.
I mean, who doesn't love
chili over tater tots.
I mean potato barrels.
If you've ever been to Ohana,
you know how good the bread pudding is.
It's easier to make at
home than you would expect,
and you get to flambe, which sounds scary,
but I swear it's not.
I'm telling you now,
if the spring roll cart
in Magic Kingdom is open,
you best believe you can find me there.
I'm making the pepperoni ones,
but I also have the recipe
for the cheeseburger ones,
so take your pick on what you like.
They come together really quick,
and you also can make
these in the air fryer.
And finally,
my favorite snack slash
meal in all of Disney World.
I have recipe tested
this one so many times,
and I think I have come
close to perfection
to making the Ronto Wrap at home,
so check it out.
Here's how you make
the cheddar cheese soup
from Le Cellier in Epcot.
This recipe is pretty simple.
We're starting off by
frying up some bacon.
And to that, we're adding
celery and red onion.
Once that's cooked,
we're going to add in
some flour for thickness.
As always, the full recipe will be posted
over on my Instagram.
Then it's just a process.
We're adding some chicken
stock, letting that simmer.
I know that Le Cellier is
technically a steakhouse,
but I think this is probably
the most famous dish
on their menu.
Once that's simmered down and thick,
we're adding in some milk.
The creaminess of the soup
will really come together
in the last 15-minute simmer.
You can't have cheddar cheese
soup without cheddar cheese.
We're adding in eight ounces
of shredded cheddar cheese.
I prefer to shred my own.
I just think it gives it a
better texture in the soup.
And then it's your final spices,
which is Tabasco,
Worcestershire, salt, and pepper,
and it's Canada,
so we're finishing it off
with a 1/4 cup of beer.
Be sure to follow along for
even more Disney Parks recipes.
Do you recognize this snack?
Let's head over to Magic Kingdom
and recreate one of my
all-time favorite sweet treats,
the Cheshire Cat Tail.
We're starting this recipe on the stove
with some milk and vanilla,
and we're just heating that up.
We're making an easy creme pat.
The whole recipe will be
posted over on my Instagram
if you have any questions.
But then we're just taking
eggs, sugar, and corn starch,
giving that a mix.
And then we're slowly adding
the heated milk mixture
back into the eggs, just
so we don't scramble them.
It's called tempering.
And that goes back on the stove
until it gets thick and bubbly.
Then we're just rolling out
some frozen puff pastry,
we're topping it with that creme pat,
and then we're also topping
it with mini chocolate chips.
This is my favorite sweet
treat in Magic Kingdom.
It usually has its own stand,
but right now, you can
find it at Cosmic Ray's.
Then we're just holding it
over, essentially like a book,
and then we're just going to cut it
in one and a 1/2 inch section,
pop them in on
parchment-lined baking sheet,
give them a twist,
and bake them in a 400-degree
oven until golden brown.
Once cooled, it's time to ice,
and that's just powdered sugar, milk,
and a bit of food coloring.
Use a spoon to drizzle,
and you've gotten yourself
a Cheshire Cat Tail
from Magic Kingdom.